the Joe Rogan experience what events you
really shine in log presses my bread and
butter we talked about then there's the
yoke walk which is you know the crossbar
with stance picking up on your back and
walk with it you know that's one event
that I'm really well known for as well
and this one that Martines tends to
struggle at so why are you so good at
that what's the deal um people call me
like Fred Flintstone of strongman like I
doesn't move my feet really really quick
I don't know like I just got ID for some
reason I just like you know feeling
super heavy weight on my back and moving
quick with you you know world Strongest
Man we had a thirteen hundred and fifty
pounds on that thing it was a [ __ ] and
now is actually the end of a medley so
we had a farmer's walk that was three
hundred thirty pounds per hand and then
we had to pick up a 1,000 pound yoke and
then the thirteen hundred and fifty yeah
and I was the only one in my group to
actually finish that event which was
pretty wild
god damn you at the end of something
like that all your tissues must be so
torn apart like yeah it was like I mean
you talk about like cranial pressure
like my I felt like my eyes were purple
it was wild
yeah I would imagine right that kind of
cream have you ever do you know what
happens when you fly in a jet it's going
like the g-forces yeah you know you have
to they call it hooking where you like
hold on to the handle you gotta go I
guess but then you're forcing that luck
pretty much what we're doing because
with strongman like when you have 1,300
pounds on your back like you're not
gonna breathe that well like you can't
really expand your lungs and your ribs
to breathe proper almost holding your
breath so and that's with most of our
stuff like I hold my breath whenever I
do moving events and I just try to
exhale and inhale as shortened as small
as possible just to get enough so I
don't pass out pretty much does anybody
pass out all the time what am i one of
my good friends at world Strongest Man
in the Philippines on 2018 we were
carrying like a 330 pound sandbag and
like the way he carried it was just like
resting rat on his diaphragm and he
didn't pick it up high enough to go onto
the platform so he just ran into the
platform fell backwards
and was just out cold and Magnus ver
Magnusson is standing right next to him
another awesome name great name didn't
twitch didn't move a muscle he just goes
died just like any passing out kind of
like a normal part of what we do I can
only imagine it doesn't stop it doesn't
sound good when I'm saying it out loud
well it makes sense though I mean the
[ __ ] user ssin does anybody have
heart attacks not typically it's it has
happened the only person that comes to
mind is a guy I can't remember what year
his name was Jesse Monday and he did
have a heart attack in the gym when he
was training and that's how he passed
away and he was only I believe he's only
28 or 29 years old it happens in
jiu-jitsu yeah I was getting heart
attacks training and then you know I
mean another thing is like sleep apnea
because the guys are so big so that
causes a lot of stress on the heart you
use a CPAP machine or anything I don't I
I don't need one you know I'm pretty
fortunate that I don't have that issue
when I sleep you know but a previous
coach of mine Mike Jenkins he passed
away in 2013 because of sleep apnea and
you know just the strain on his heart so
yeah that's not good it's basically not
sleeping yeah you're in suffocating
yourself yeah it's crazy so a lot of the
guys that this level do but I mean that
but that's mainly like because of their
size you and I have it really yeah yeah
yeah it's might have fat tongue but
that's all the years of fighting like
what that neck you musculature and all
that development there yeah for some
reason like I've kind of you know got
lucky josepho all players have it for
sure how our lifter side I think when
you want once you get around that
300-pound body weight like do you snore
not terribly hmm on planes I do but
that's because my bad mouth just opens
up yeah so a good place to sleep now or
just sit in general when you're near 300
pounds
[Applause]